the the the text of the film itself is  kind of pulling apart with these two  dramatic elements that that do not  cohere in a way that that makes it so  fundamentally  um at odds with with the majority of of  the Cinematic language of of  um of of Marvel so  I know I'm I'm rambling a little bit but  um  that's essentially my question if you  could speak on that  yeah the reflective nature of Thor I  think  um  look dude all of us you know and I don't  mean like sorry before you answer like I  don't mean the the uh the the language  itself is broken down to to the point  wherein we cannot we can no longer  identify with the character because  that's that's what the cinema is it's  it's Spielberg it's Scorsese